now Ukraine would have been the talk of
the town in Washington all this week if
they hadn't spent the whole last seven
days party planning for last night the
White House Correspondents Dinner
lovingly called nerd prom we call it the
nerd prom we did not prom amazingly it's
actually even worse than it sounds it is
alarming display of coziness where you
can see such majestic sights as National
Security Advisor Susan Rice asking for
an autograph from the guy from duck
dynasty both of them could justifiably
look the other one in the eyes and say
what the are you doing here and
they'd both be right it's a night when
journalists celebrate their independence
by hanging out with their sources and
celebrates their importance by utterly
ignoring one another in favor of
Hollywood stars in fact the main purpose
of the evening seems to be providing
photos of glamorous celebrities
completely unaware of who they are
standing next to